an avalanche of problems within the u.s
postal service
could keep votes from being counted in
2020
more americans than ever before are
expected to vote by mail this year
and since the usps has a monopoly over
letter delivery
those ballots will have to go through
the postal service
but years of financial problems recent
budget cuts
and a strain from the pandemic is
slowing the system down
threatening our democracy
in 19 states your ballot needs to be
postmarked by a certain date to count
now only the u.s postal service can
issue a legally valid postmark
fedex cannot postmark your ballot ups
cannot postmark your ballot only the
postal service can do that
the problems begin with sorting machines
which are crucial to a quick delivery
but the postal service has been planning
on dismantling them since may
and many have already been removed from
distribution centers
across the country which could slow down
all sorts of mail delivery
including ballots ballot and election
males don't get special treatment
on their own in the postal system for
being election mail they're just
processed in with all the other first
class
mail mail and voting includes both
universal mail-in ballots and absentee
ballots
some states send mail ballots to every
registered voter
while others require voters to apply for
an absentee ballot ahead of the election
that process results in a lot of mail
and state election offices
depend on the usps to deliver it
only the usps can go into mailboxes
they sort of have this monopoly over
letters and first class
mail but not packages and if the postal
service can't deliver
and return applications and ballots on
time those votes
might not be counted as a voter you know
you have a lot a lot of agency over
making sure your vote gets counted even
in a crazy pandemic time
if you are voting by mail you should go
and request your ballot now
do not wait until the last minute this
is a concept you know experts refer to
as flattening the curve of mail ballot
requests
some states also offer other ways to
return your ballot
like in drop boxes or by hand delivering
them to local election offices
the postal service was already dealing
with mail delays
thanks in part to reforms implemented by
postmaster general
lewis dejoy those reforms led to
cost-cutting measures
like slashing overtime and limiting late
delivery shifts
financial problems at the usps aren't
new
but president donald trump's recent
attacks on universal mail-in voting
brought national attention to the
reforms
they're trying it again with this whole
80 million mail-in ballots that they're
working on
sending them out to people that didn't
ask for them and it's not fair and it's
not right
the other part of it is you know the
pandemic has been really really scary
for people and it's undermined a lot of
people's faith and trust in their
government
dejoy told senators that the postal
service will no longer be dismantling
machines prior to the election
but those that were already removed
won't be replaced
he also said that postal employees will
be approved for overtime
to process mail-in votes and in a
contentious house hearing
dejoy promised that mail-in voting would
be safe
i am not engaged in sabotaging the
election we will
do everything within our power and
structure to deliver ballots on time
but many worry this isn't enough
especially because of issues processing
ballots during the primaries
election offices dealt with just a
massive massive influx people requesting
mail ballots at the last minute there
were people a lot of people in some
states who didn't get their ballots at
all
or you know got their ballots on the day
of the election or when it was too late
to return them
in july the postal service sent a letter
to 46 states in washington d.c
warning that their registration
deadlines might not provide enough time
for the agency to deliver ballots
and though concerns about a contentious
election are at the forefront of the
postal service debate
other problems will persist after
november
more people are interested and concerned
about the post office than maybe ever
before because of the impending election
but you know it's important to step back
and look at the big picture and
the financial problems with the postal
service are not going away
these are big existential questions
about the post office's future and what
it'll look like that
are not going to go away after the
election
[Music]
you